welcome back to las vegas now three
square needs the community's help with
ending childhood hunger so here's how
you can get involved
always happy to spread the word about
what you guys are doing so i hear that
it's your ninth year for the bad
childhood hunger campaign
congratulations
thank you so much we're super excited
yeah the the campaign's really important
as you know
and this is the time of year we raise we
raise annually about two million dollars
to support our childhood
program so yeah it's a super important
time and
and everyone we need everyone to get
involved absolutely so let's just
introduce people
who are out there that aren't familiar
with the campaign what are you guys
doing and how does it work
nevada gold mines operated by barrick
and nv energy
both put up some dollars for the
community to be matched
so for every one dollar that comes into
three square we typically can create
three meals
during this time frame from now through
the end of may every one dollar donated
creates six meals for people
that are struggling with hunger right
now in our community that is incredible
and of course
specifically to southern nevada and our
community you know what are you seeing
out there
what are what are the rates of childhood
hunger you know uh pre-covert we had
about a hundred and two thousand
kids that were food insecure and just
for reference there are about 500 000
kids here in southern nevada
at the height of the pandemic that grew
by another 70
000 kids to about 173 000 kids
right now the latest information we just
got back we it now shows our 2021
estimates at about 131 000 kids that are
food insecure
so that's one in every four of our kids
that are food insecure
we'd like to get those numbers back to
where they were pre-covered and where
they should be which is that
no children in our community are food
insecure
absolutely and of course that is a call
to action for the community how can we
get involved and help you guys
help our children yeah it's pretty
simple go
online threesquare.org make a donation
every dollar helps every dollar right
now is creating six
meals for your neighbors and kids here
in southern nevada
beautiful okay and michelle lastly here
any encouraging words or last words
you want to say um to our viewers about
three square and what you guys are doing
with this campaign
you know i just want to say thank you so
much for the ongoing support
this community has stepped up in a big
way during the pandemic
it's it's the rally around it's the
vegas strong
they are not wanting to see anybody
that's going
you know having a hard day not have a
meal to eat so
um it's just keep up the good work
that's what we need to do it's a fight
we all can win
absolutely the three square food bank is
on north pecos road for more information
just call 702-644-3663
or visit threesquare.org we'll be right